let's go to our caller from the 718
area code who's calling today from 718.
yeah what's up uh my name is danny from
brooklyn
danny from brooklyn what neighborhood in
brooklyn
bay ridge bay ridge that is a that is
that is one of the top neighborhoods i
would say
yeah oh well i guess so
all right well you're not thrilled about
bay ridge but what's on your mind today
uh well it's very right-leaning so you
know that's true
that's uh the major downside of it but
uh my question is
so if but when trump leaves office i
not going not going to be silent like
other
past presidents or a courteous in that
way
i can imagine he's uh he'll be on fox
news every morning
and sean hannity and o'han so what kind
of
impact do you believe this will have
on society do you believe it will be
like having two presidents
where his face will listen to his
command or
that's a good question yeah yeah so
imagine so so you're saying
biden wins and trump loses whatever the
hell trump does between november 3rd and
january 20th eventually trump leaves
and biden is the actual president but
trump continues to tweet
and he continues to be interviewed
you're saying beyond that trump
continues to tweet and be interviewed
and say here's what i would be doing
here's what which should be doing
will he have enough followers where him
running almost like a parallel
presidency could have an impact
exactly yeah i honestly it's possible
and it's very scary
it's very scary the idea because i think
that you know
um 60 plus million people are going to
vote for the guy
and if he sort of never really leaves
the public eye the way george w
bush did in the immediate aftermath of
his presidency the way barack obama did
for a time after his presidency um
it could wreak absolute in total havoc
yeah so that's interesting but you know
what
i'm okay dealing with that problem when
we get to it as long as we remove him
okay i see yeah it's just uh you know
i'm just thinking
you know because i don't imagine him
being silent like barack obama or george
w
bush you know i'm 90 with you i think
there's
10 of me that thinks maybe because
trump's this huge narcissist
it's possible trump if he loses will say
i didn't want a second term anyway and i
don't want anything to do with politics
anyway
and we never hear from him again i think
that's like a one in ten
i think the nine and ten is what exactly
what you're talking about which is he
won't shut up
gotcha all right all right dave i love
your show man thank you
thank you all right say hi to everybody
in brooklyn for me i miss miss living in
brooklyn brooklyn's great
just a just a great place